We're on problem 21.
Which product is equivalent
to 4x squared minus 16
over 2 minus x?
So let's see if we can simplify
this a little bit.
4x squared minus 16, if we were
to factor out a 4, that's
the same thing as 4 times
x squared minus 4.
That's 4x squared minus 16, all
of that over 2 minus x.
Then x squared minus 4, that's
that same pattern that keeps
showing up, a squared minus
b squared, right?
So that numerator becomes 4
times x plus 2 times x minus
2, right? a plus b
times a minus b.
Then the denominator, let's
think about it.
This has 2 minus x, and we
have an x minus 2 here.
But what if we were to factor
out a negative 1 from this?
What happens?
If you factor out a negative 1,
then the negative x becomes
a positive x, and the positive
2 becomes a minus 2.
I did that just to show you that
a negative, if you divide
this by or multiply by
a negative 1, you
just switch the order.
2 minus x becomes x minus 2,
which is a good thing to
recognize because we have an x
minus 2 in the numerator, too.
So this will cancel
out with that.
If we assume that x does not
ever equal 2 because x
equaling 2 would make this an
undefined statement because
you can't divide by zero, but if
we make that assumption, we
can cancel those out.
Then we have 4 divided by
negative 1 is minus 4
times x plus 2.
That is choice D.
Next question, 22.
I like this cutting and pasting
of the actual question.
It makes it fun.
I don't want it to slow down
my computer too much.
I sound like I'm melting
when that happens.
So that's our problem.
I didn't write the
choices down.
All right, let's see
what we can do.
So they have x squared
plus 4x.
Let me write this.
x squared plus 4x over x plus 3
times x squared minus 9, all
of that over x squared
plus x minus 12.
You might say, oh, my God, to
multiply these using algebraic
multiplication would take
forever, then I'd have to
factor it and simplify it.
The trick here is to factor it
and simplify it before you do
any multiplication.
So let's simplify each of these
expressions and cancel
out as much as possible.
So here we can just
factor out an x.
So this just becomes
x times x plus 4.
This is a squared minus b
squared, so this becomes x
plus 3 times x minus 3.
With that you can't do much.
Let's think about this one.
What two numbers add up to a 1,
a 1x, and when you multiply
them, you get a minus 12?
So let's see, if you have an x
plus 4 times x minus 3, that
should work.
4 minus 3 is 1.
4 times minus 3 is minus 12.
So that works.
All right now we're
ready to cancel.
Normally.
I would just start canceling,
but I just
want to make the point.
So this is equal to x times x
plus 4 times these, x plus 3
times x minus 3, all of that
over x plus 3 times x plus 4
times x minus 3.
Now we can cancel.
We have an x minus 3, x minus
3, x plus 4 x plus 4, x plus
3, x plus 3, and all we're
left with is an x.
So all of this fancy expression,
all that
equals is an x.
That's choice B.
Where am I?
Next problem.
Image, clear image, invert
colors, there you go.
All right, let me see
if I have to copy
and paste this one.
Where was I?
Oh, why not?
Another one where they're
trying to get
the simplest form.
So I copied it.
Let me paste it.
All right, I hope you
can read this.
So what is the simplest form
of this expression here?
I'll rewrite it.
5x to the third y plus 20x
squared y squared plus 20x y
to the third, everything
divided by 5xy.
So 5xy actually goes
into every one of
these terms, right?
Let's just get rid of the 5's.
Well, actually, let's just
divide the numerator and the
denominator by 5xy.
So what's 5x to the third
y divided by 5xy?
Well, 5 divided by 5-- I'll
do it in magenta.
5 divided by 5 is 1 so we don't
have to write that.
x to the third divided
by x is x squared.
y divided by y is 1.
So this term divided by this
term reduced to that.
Easy enough.
Next one.
Plus 20 divided by 5 is 4.
x squared divided by x is x.
y squared divided by y is y.
We did the second term.
Let's do the third term.
20 divided by 5 is 4.
x divided by x is 1 so we don't
have to write it. y to
the third divided by
y is y squared.
What we have here is this
simplified, but that doesn't
look like anything here.
So my guess is that this is
probably one of these.
This is the square
of something.
Let's see if we can
factor this.
This would be x.
So what two numbers when I add
them become 4xy or what number
when I multiply it times x is
equal to half of this-- that's
another way to think about it--
and when I square it is
equal to 4y squared?
That's just plus 2y squared.
If that didn't make a lot of
sense, multiply this out and
you'll get this answer.
When you look at the choices,
you should just say, OK, I
know that this choice and
this choice, those look
nothing like that.
Then you say, oh, well,
maybe this is one of
these choices, right?
But you have a 4y
squared here.
This one has no y
at all in it.
So you can even just use
deductive reasoning to say,
oh, the choice must be
x plus 2y squared.
Next problem.
OK, this one I'm definitely
going to copy and paste
because they have a big image.
All right, let me see
if I can do it.
This makes it a lot easier than
having to draw it myself.
All right.
If i equals the square root of
negative 1, which, if you
didn't know it, that's what i
is defined as, and I go on
many videos about the magical
of i and e and pi.
Which point shows the location
of 5 minus 2i on the plane?
The x-axis is the real axis.
You take the real part,
which is 5.
So you go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So that's the real part.
Then the y-axis is the
imaginary axis.
You take the imaginary part,
minus 2i, minus 2, right?
So you go down 2 in the i
direction and you're at point
D, which is choice D.
Fair enough.
That problem had a lot
of graphics but
was unusually simple.
Next problem.
OK, now they're giving us a
whole parade of imaginary
number questions.
So this one I don't have to
cut, copy, and paste.
They say if i is equal to the
square root of negative 1,
which is a definition that we've
all learned, what is the
value of i to the fourth?
Well let's just go back.
Let's say you've never seen
i before in your life.
Let's think about it.
If i is equal to negative 1--
sorry, this is negative 1.
I know that negative looks
like it got messed up.
Let's square both sides
of this equation.
i squared will be equal
to negative 1.
Now, let's square both sides
of this equation.
i squared squared is equal
to negative 1 squared.
Well, i squared squared is just
i to the fourth, right?
2 times 2 is equal to negative
1 squared, which is
just equal to 1.
And we're done.
That's choice C.
All right, now they have another
imaginary graph.
So let me just copy and
paste this graph.
I'll go here.
There you go.
I didn't have to erase
what I had before.
The question they ask us: Which
of the following complex
numbers is represented by the
point on the graph below?
So we just have to figure
out the real and
the imaginary parts.
So what's the real part?
This coordinate, its
real part is 3.
Its imaginary part is
minus 4 right there.
So it's 3, and its imaginary
part, minus 4 in
the imaginary direction.
And we're done.
3 minus 4i.
That's choice C.
I'm almost out of time.
I'll see you in the
next video.